hi guys how's it going I'm here with the
kyer family it's David Tammy and Melissa
they wanted to say hi and I wanted to
give an opportunity to say hi to you
guys so whatever you guys would like to
say the floor is open for you guys to
speak yeah we certainly want to thank
the folks that contributed to the
GoFundMe to cover expenses for Danny's
death for us and truly truly appreciate
that always have wanted to reach out to
everyone also to thank everybody for
giving Daniel support through his
synagogue stuff and then of course Mark
were always grateful to mark for giving
Daniel what Senate like time opportunity
sympathizes trees and God we'll never
know we'll never know why he did what he
did he has so much scheming so much
going for him this is so hard coming out
here it really is but it's part of what
we got to do I mean you know when we
come out here with this is the last
place that Daniel breathed his last
willful breath you know when we came in
song an ICU he wasn't breathing on his
own anymore so here is where he actually
was breathing his last breath so you to
come out here with so many mixed
emotions you come out here with love for
the whole thing and feeling his presence
and seeing what could have been and then
dealing with the thought of the
catastrophic event that has just changed
our lives forever in we know we don't
look for sympathy we know that a lot of
people go through a lot of tragedy and
and we're just worth right through it
that the best you can
I've read all the literature everyone
knows all this if anyone has gone
through any kind of tragedy like this
and you don't ever get over it you just
embed it into your everyday life and and
somehow the scar tissue covers it it
opens up every once in a while but I can
tell you you know let others speak but
from my point is six months seems like
yesterday but we're getting through it
actually we're fighting hard and I reach
out to all of you that have gone through
anything like this just to keep on
working at please just keep on working
at it because it may not happen we love
all of you for what support was given to
Daniel thank you so much thanks for
speaking I'd like also thank some of the
youtubers that reached out to us the
fans you guys are amazing we got letters
cards flowers all kind of stuff on in
Daniels name and we just really
appreciate everything that you guys have
done I'd like to also thank bazooka tree
for the beautiful tribute that I almost
put together a first-in ago I just I
just can't quit watching it it's just so
so good I would just like to say thank
you for everyone who's still supporting
us like I see on Instagram and I'm sure
they get it too you know all the fans
comment on my stuff and are just
constantly there for me and I think it's
amazing so thank you all for still being
there for us means a lot yeah and just
thank you from me to you guys for you
know being so like supportive of us and
coming out here
Oh what we feel is nothing compared to
what you guys feel but I'm glad that we
can all still you know stay together in
this and have a good time coming out
here as best we can and I just want to
say you know thank you for inspiring us
to stay strong and you know helping Ryan
out yeah Ryan's very close to the men he
found Daniels so he's almost like
extended family with this situation but
damn it you to me you were here you gave
him the opportunity
you also it's it's devastating to all of
us but we've always not wanted any of
you here to feel guilty about it it's no
one's fault when someone commits suicide
it's always a perfect storm no one knows
why so there's an I mean a mark makes a
good point we can come out here and
fellowship with mark and Matt and Ryan
and in a way that's healthy actually it
is at the same time that we're
experiencing the last place that we love
them mark and thank you guys for taking
the time to speak I'm sure everyone out
there appreciate us hearing these words
and if anyone out there ever is going
through any struggle there's a reason
why I put so much importance in to the
charity livestreams that involved you
know help lines and crisis text line and
stuff like that like if you need help
please reach out because it does affect
a wide amount of people and it does
affect a lot and and if you know someone
that's going through struggles please
reach out to them struggle or try to
help them as best
you can so yeah any final closing things
my man again just thanks her in her body
love to everybody really then thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next one bye